[Musique]
comme des chiens vous cuisiner des plats
fait plein de tradition du sud ouest
nous est pas mal
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous faites des concours d'imitation
labello
c'est vrai qu'on se demande ce que mange
igor et grichka fut-elle multiplient
chez
[Applaudissements]
les répondu quoi
le gars il est dans son
ses passagers magouilles et messieurs
[Rires]
j'ai vomi louis
[Applaudissements]
et
comme les frères bogdanoff savait que
cyril était absolument clients de leur
accent évidemment ils sont revenus sur
le plateau de touche pas à mon poste et
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
les actions du sud ou
et que ça peut te [ __ ]
et tu as mangé un chien
qui fait deux fois
[Rires]
la machine est bon c'est quoi la magie
des bouchons dans les oreilles
je suis inondé de messages de
gens qui visiblement a passé vous avez
passé une soirée des gaston vous n'en
avez dansé avec lui avec un cast on
savait qu'à satisfaire il le dit comme
il sait tous déjà une petite fille une
petite faute à
[Rires]
une autre une autre fois non ça c'est
tout
je me demande si gaston bachelard ce
essaie de ne pas me faire terminer
l'émission la dernière photo je peux pas
vous la montre est mature
[Applaudissements]
et entre nous
non non j'essaie de voir ma scop non
mais visiblement vous connaissez bien
c'est un manga tombe à cela